-It's so nice to see you.
You've been on the show a bunch
of times separately.
The first time together.
-That's right.
-What better way
to start your season?
-Mother and daughter, yes.
You both look great.
Welcome, and thanks for being
here. Appreciate it.
How are the grandkids?
-They are so great.
-Three now right, Chelsea?
-Three.
Seven, six, and three. Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh.
-And we had the best summer.
How was your summer?
-It was unbelievable.
-Yeah.
-Very, very lucky.
We're just happy and good.
And the kids are great.
I know you spoil your kids --
your grandkids.
-Just a little.
-She does, Jimmy.
Then ask did she spoil me?
[ Laughter ]
-She did. She did.
-Did she? She didn't.
-No, no, it skips a generation.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that how it works?
-Yeah, yeah, you're supposed to
both spoil
and be kind of subversive.
-Yeah, I understand.
-Like, do you need to have
ice cream three times a day?
-Yeah.
That's what a good grandma does.
-I want happy grandchildren.
-Even with bribery.
And then, you know, Chelsea
limits screen time,
which I think is right.
It's absolutely right.
-But do you limit screen time?
-Well...
[ Laughter ]
I just feel like there's
so much they can learn.
[ Laughter ]
-That's exactly right.
-I go for a run, and my mom's
like, "Just one video."
And I'm like, "Okay."
And I come back from my run
like an hour later,
and she's like,
"So, we're on the 17th
volcano explosion."
And I was like,
"Did we need the last 15?"
-They've really seen a lot of
volcano explosions.
They can learn a lot.
-And the megalodon.
The gigantic prehistoric shark.
-Oh, yeah.
There are so many great videos
to see.
-I just can't stop.
-I'm happy that you're here.
I want to talk to you about
your show on Apple TV+, "Gutsy."
But I wanted to ask you both,
since you both
lived at the White House.
-Yes, we did.
-Yes.
How easy is it to walk out with
boxes of classified documents?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's the plural that kills me,
right?
You're like not just
one box or one document --
boxes and thousands of
documents.
-Does he know what he's doing?
What would you do with that?
I mean, is it for -- is it
for the presidential library?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, usually when it comes to
presidential libraries,
everything is in the archives.
We have a National Archive
and Record Administration
where everything goes.
And then it gets transferred to
a presidential library.
At least that's the way
it used to happen.
[ Laughter ]
-Now he's got his own stash
in his basement.
-Yeah, I guess.
I mean, that's what
we're finding out.
-I also wanted to ask you --
I got the opportunity,
honored to talk to the president
of Ukraine, President Zelenskyy.
And as Secretary of State,
I know you've been to Ukraine
many times.
What are the next steps
for Ukraine?
-Well, look, I am thrilled that
they have gotten the support
and solidarity of
so much of the world.
Obviously, Europe,
the United States, Canada,
but Japan, other places.
They're getting the weapons
they need to defend themselves,
and they're now on offense.
And I think we have to keep
supporting them, helping them.
They were attacked by
an unprovoked act of war,
and they've held out
and they've done better
than anybody could have
predicted.
And Zelenskyy has been
a true wartime leader.
I'm so impressed with him.
-Absolutely.
-And I think, you know,
the United States should stand
with him along with all of our
other friends around the world.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I agree.
Let's talk about "Gutsy."
"Gutsy" is a docuseries based on
your best-selling book.
-Yes.
-"The Book of Gutsy Women."
-Right.
-When you did that book,
which of course we have
at the house,
did you think, "Oh, we can make
a show out of this?"
-No. No.
-It was just a continuation of a
conversation we had been having
my whole life of stories
that have inspired us
that we wanted to share, stories
we were starting to share
with the grandchildren.
Thankfully, she gives them
a diet of inspiration
along with the third bowl of
chocolate chip ice cream.
And then we had the chance
to turn it into a series.
And it was just such a joy.
-It's been so much fun.
-So much fun.
-You guys are obviously
fantastic together,
but I don't know if many get to
see this side of you guys
as mother/daughter
and almost like a comedy team
when you're talking.
You both go at it.
-I mean, there's just so much
to make fun of.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-She has never stopped.
Literally.
I remember --
-It's my --
-She's a pretty good "put you
in your place" kind of person.
-With love.
-With love, yeah, sure.
She was like three or four,
and I say to her, you know,
I think I should
as her mother, I say,
"You know, Chelsea,
it's cold outside.
You should wear
a sweater or jacket."
She goes, "I don't want to."
I said, "Well, I know,
but it's cold."
She goes, "Mom, if you're cold,
wear a sweater or a jacket."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's a great line!
"Hey, if you're cold, wear one."
-So that kind of runs
through the series.
-It's very funny.
-She makes a lot of fun of me.
-It's very good.
But also you know
what you're doing, too.
It's so good, but also
I love that you interview people
like Megan Thee Stallion.
And then you interview women
like Jane Goodall.
-Yes.
-And you go, "Oh, two women of
two different things,
both powerful,
both inspiring
in different ways."
I love that you did that
and you do that.
Also you take some chances on
this docuseries from what I saw,
especially Chelsea.
-Yes.
-You're like rappelling down
a mountain
and training with the FDNY.
-I mean, okay, I can't quite
call it training.
I mean, I put on the gear
and I tried.
[ Laughter ]
-I think just putting on
the gear and walking up stairs
is training.
-I was trying to haul that hose.
It was really humbling
and I feel like gratitude is
an insufficient word
for how in awe I am
of our women of the FDNY.
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
You get to see it.
You take it for granted,
you know?
Is there a certain person that
you had on the show that you go,
"I want to make sure this person
gets a chance to say something"?
-Oh, there were so many of them.
And partly, Jimmy, because,
you know,
a lot of them we didn't know.
We might have known of them,
but we had never met them.
And I'll just give you a quick
recap of --
We actually met a woman who used
to be a white supremacist
and got out of that life and now
tries to deprogram others.
And she takes them into nature,
so we went down to Georgia.
We went canoeing on a river
together.
And she talked about
her life journey.
And there was a young woman
with her whose last name
we didn't use because she had
just come out of that movement
of hate and violence.
-And testified against
some of the worst neo-Nazi
white supremacists.
-So you're with these women
and you find common ground,
even though their experiences
are very different.
And then the next thing I did
was to interview two women
who had lost their children
to hate crimes.
One was the mother of
Heather Heyer,
who was murdered
in Charlottesville,
and the other was a black woman.
Her son had just been admitted,
got his commission
in our military after being in
ROTC, was standing,
minding his own business
and somebody yelling
racial epithets
stabbed him to death.
And talking to these women
who'd experienced
about the worst thing you could
from this kind of hate,
that sadly, unfortunately, is
too much in our lives today,
they were so amazing in how they
were talking about they had to
get through their grief and
their hatred and their outrage
so that they could continue with
their lives
and try to do something to help
other people.
So it goes from the funny --
We went to Paris
and went to the clown school
and put on the red noses
and the whole deal --
all the way to Syria.
-We're secretly coming
for your job.
-I know.
I can tell, every appearance.
-I want to see you
with the red nose.
-Everyone knows I'm a clown.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Hillary
and Chelsea Clinton in "Gutsy."
Take a look at this.
-Going back to Arkansas helps us
really think through
some of these questions about
"What does gutsiness
really mean?
How do you make
difficult choices?
How do you take a leap, a leap
of faith sometimes that you have
no idea what the outcome is
going to be?"
Going back is something
I'm looking forward to.
-Me too.
-I don't know if you're going to
get much more in there.
You'll be surprised.
That's very expandable.
Oh, yeah, I got lots of room.
-Ready to sit on your suitcase?
-No, I don't need --
It's very...reliable.
-I know.
You're very loyal to
that suitcase.
-I am.
[ Thunk ]
-Oh, good Lord. Alright.
-Okay, we're done!
Let's head to Arkansas!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sit on it?
Hillary and Chelsea Clinton,
everyone.
"Gutsy" premieres this Friday
on Apple TV+.
When we come back, Hillary and
Chelsea are going head-to-head
in the Mother Daughter
Challenge. Stick around.